welcome to the last meet up of 2023 we
survived another year yeah I heard some
claps thank you but I will tell you all
right that was very that was very low
all right so uh we're here I want to
thank um NYU and particularly George for
making this happen the past few months
and this month everyone thank you George
give a round of applause for
George uh so the first thing we always
ask at the meet up is is anyone hiring
now those of you that are watching us
virtually through the live stream you
can't tell us you're Hing so if you are
go to the NY hackr slack uh you'll find
the link at nyck r.org on the top right
of the website there's a job postings
Channel let us know if you're hiring if
you're in the room if anyone is hiring
in the room raise your hand I know these
are tough times in the economy so if
you're not hiring I get it if anyone is
hiring tell us if not go to the job
postings
channel for those of you in the room we
got the pizza today from John's of bleer
so I want everyone to vote on the pizza
so you can pull out your phones and go
to bit. lee/ pizzle ignore any buzzing
or alarms you hear that's someone
opening the wrong door and there's
always a buzzing but pick up your phones
bit.ly Pizza pole and rank the place
it's on a fiveo scale let us know how it
is from you know essentially 1 to five
it's categorical but it's order
categorical what that one more time bit.
leple all
lowercase for those of you that are
watching from home go into the chat and
let us know where you're eating from and
there's two chats available there is the
live stream chat right there on YouTube
and there's also the slack um we have a
slack for the mic group again Nyack
guard.org and you'll find a link to
slack and you can go in there go to the
monthly Meetup monthly meetup events
Channel and let us know where you're
getting food from if you get pizza
awesome if you get other food cool let
us know what you're eating everyone in
the room took the time to vote excellent
so those of you that are newer to the
group we we've been collecting data for
about 10 years on the pizza we've been
serving every month from a different
place we'll do some repeat so it's
longitudinal we'll do some places that I
think are really good some places I
think maybe not be as good some places I
don't know and we want to see how the
data shakes out if you go to nar.org
there is a live JavaScript bar plot of
people voting and the data is available
as a live Json feed at my website
jer.com it is available and you can pull
it and analyze it any way you please I
know it was used for tidy Tuesday one
time use it for anything you like it is
open freely available anyone can use
it a member of our team that has been uh
instrumental in helping us put these
things on just came back from her
wedding so everyone give Nicole a round
of
applause it's been a month so
congratulations lasting a
month we are very excited we have put on
a few conferences throughout the year
can can I announce the conferences the
vi the the videos they're up all right
we just put up the videos cool for two
conferences the D4 conference was a
general purpose data design Discovery
conference and the r in government
conference which a few people in this
room spoke at at least three of us spoke
there so your videos are up online so
check it out you can go to d4c con. and
you go to
rats. and there's a link for videos all
those videos are up and we're really
excited to have people watching them and
enjoying them this is the last speak
speaker the last Meetup of the year
because it's December we are ready to
get started next year in January and
February March but we need speakers we
have the space thanks to George we need
speakers now so anyone wants to give a
talk send me a message you can find me
on the NY hackr slack LinkedIn Twitter
Mastadon J lander.com Facebook I don't
care how you get in touch with me find a
way to get in touch with me email me uh
we want speakers we're always looking
for more and more people to give talks
otherwise I have to volunteer people and
that does happen and I will do that pick
people randomly so let us know and the
topic could be any topic this is the
open statistical programming Meetup that
means R python Julia go SQL it could be
about a math talk it could be a
conceptual talk it could be about
databases it could be about applied uses
it's a very big tent we could talk about
anything we all have talks during the we
all have questions during the talks
people in the room you can raise your
hand and you ask the question directly
if you're coming virtually you obviously
can't just stand up and raise your hand
ask a question in the chat again either
the live stream chat or in the uh slack
chat and we will collate your questions
and we will ask the speaker the
questions for you to get you your
answers so if you're virtual ask them as
you please if you're in person we'll
save them up for the
end also if you're in person we are
going to go to the bar afterwards we're
going to arts and crafts bar if you know
where that is you're going to lead
people if you don't know where it is
you're going to follow people all right
easy as can be wonderful so I hope
everyone's here is ready for an exciting
talk we're all going to learn a lot if
everyone could give a big round of
applause for
Andy all
right
okay cool am I now good on the mic all
right cool so regularized breaking
extends this framework and allows for
more explicit and granular tradeoffs to
be made about the properties of our
weight sets these include things like
the variance of the weights these
include things like how exactly we want
our weights to match population totals
so two real goals for the talk first I
want to review vanilla riking and
clarify in what sense the weights it
produces are optimal and then I want to
argue that vanilla Ring's implicit
objective is increasingly a poor fit for
modern survey inference and show why
regularized raking is a good framework
for improvements to be clear not the
only framework for improvements right
but one of many good options that can
help us make better better better
inferences as we increasingly demand
more and more of our survey weights so
by way of an outline I'll do a quick
about me and about some of the weight
sets I've built um we're going to do
raking two ways one on easy mode where
we'll build a data generating process
show under what assumptions raking works
really well and sort of review
everything about how raking works then
we'll go into raking on hard mode this
is uh us coming smack into the face into
contact with reality unfortunately um
where things are a lot harder that'll
motivate some things we'd like to
improve about raking and we can
introduce regularized raking I'll show
some examples where regularized raking
makes a difference and then I'll end by
putting regularized raking in the
broader context of sort of the survey
weights Cinematic Universe if you want
so comparisons to multi-level regression
and poststratification things like
multi-level calibration broader
challenges of survey imprints what have
you um just one uh logistical note if
people want to take photos of the slides
go ahead but I have a QR code at the end
with a link to the reproduction
materials to make that easier for folks
so you don't have to if you don't want
to cool so quick about me I'm a data
scientist working in politics and
advertising I've been in politics since
2012 was the first race I worked on um
most recently my gig has been a mix of
politics and advertising both of these
involve a lot of thinking about weights
um I thought it'd be fun to tell you
about some of the weights I built at my
last job at 605 um these are sort of
like a wide range of things not just
surveys but they sort of underlined that
there's a lot of different situations in
which building weights like this can be
useful um so my old company 605 was a TV
viewership company right and so we had a
panel depend depending on how you count
41 million-ish households and we use
that to make inferences about the
broader us TV viewing general population
how do we wait that correctly that's a
complicated problem another thing I've
worked on a lot are political so-called
political micr targeting surveys right
you sample 5 to 10,000 people you wait
that to the voter file and then you
build out models of things like How
likely are people to vote How likely are
people to vote for a specific candidate
um I've also worked on survey based RC s
um one of the coolest ones was a covid
vaccine message testing RCT so multiarm
RCT trying to figure out which messages
work to convince people who might still
be skeptical to get the vaccine um and
then of course we wanted to wait that to
this particularly weird Universe which
is people who aren't vaccinated yet who
are customers of our Pharmacy partner
that's just sort of a sampling um I've
done some work in Market Research rcts
in politics RCT and advertising with
survey outcomes all of these are sort of
good building ground building grounds
for thinking a lot about weights so
let's get into riking on easy mode um
this is a very nice calm World um where
everything works really well um so we
have a we're going to build a
non-representative sample from a larger
universe and we're going to try to use
that sample to make inferences about the
larger
population um and our task right is how
to assign weights to each observation in
order to make that s the weighted
estimates from that sample
representative in e mode we're going to
make a lot of simplifying object like
assumptions in order to make things
better for ourselves um really the only
complexity here is that our outcome YN
is going to be correlated with some very
very basic demographics we're going to
simulate um we'll have ignorable
non-response that is conditional on the
variables we're waiting on in this case
age and race um that's all we need to
adjust for to match genp of course
that's a radical
oversimplification um but that's super
useful
in that it lets us sort of see how this
works and when this works before we move
on to anything more complicated um we
also know everything we need to wait on
to estimate YN here right this isn't a
given in the real world we don't know
everything we need to wait on to make
our our sample representative of the US
voting population for example or
whatever your target is and we also
somehow know how to measure those things
completely without error we know
everything we want about our sample we
know everything we want about our
universe without any trouble so again
nice easy world this will be helpful for
when we contrast it with the challenges
of reality in just a few slides cool so
let's build out this data generating
process we're going to build a sample of
a thousand people from a universe of
100,000 um again super simple
characteristics of the sample we've got
a nice binary age which is 50% young 50%
old to keep things simple we've got a
obviously not correct set of race
proportions again just to keep the math
when we do some raking examples really
easy and then Jared did his pizza pole
and I'm doing mine um so our outcome
here which we're going to generate from
those demographics is the probability of
someone enjoying pineapple on Pizza um I
I apologize if I'm offending anyone my
data generating process here for my
outcome so I have a biased term um where
the overall population is going to be
less likely to uh enjoy pineapple on
Pizza um and we're going to make the
people who are more like make you more
likely to enjoy pineapple on pizza if
you're white or if you're older um I
apologize if I offended anyone again
with this but had to pick something um
just like to check what we sampled to
make sure it's logical um like I said
the mean's going to be a little below
50% of people enjoying pineapple on
Pizza um and then we're going to have
this universe where there's is a
significant amount of heterogeneity here
right we''ve
got pretty wide range in this okay now
let's sample in a biased way um I'm
picking these like bad sampling weights
very deliberately so that we can have
strong intuition about what's going to
happen when we walk through riking in a
second but you're going to be we're
going to be twice as likely to sample
old folks as young folks this is really
common in surveys right it's much easier
to get old folks on the phone for
example obviously is twice as much
important no but it's useful for the
math in a slide or two um and then we'll
also make the distribution of sampling
by race entirely wrong um ideally we'd
want these all to be one I'm really
oversampling white folks somewhat under
sampling Asian folks just for the
purposes of making this really clear
what the ring is doing so if we pull
that sample calculate the sample mean
we'll get the wrong answer right um the
population mean was something like 46%
of people enjoyed pineapple on Pizza
we've got 53% um the were a horse race
pole we'd be in a bad place we'd get the
wrong answer so how do we unwind that
well we can do that with weights and we
can do that with riking um riking is a
beautiful simple intuitive algorithm and
I can actually walk you through it in a
couple of lines of code we're going to
calculate the target distribution for so
we're going to proceed variable by
variable here so first I'm going to
calculate the target distribution by age
in our sample um we're going to set up
an initial Vector of Weights um these
are just all ones um that we'll
successively add on the next next
waiting and adjustment factors
onto calculate that calculate that same
F uh same population proportion in
excuse me sample proportion right like
the proportion of young people in our
sample proportion of old people in our
sample if we join those two tables
together so we join the universe
distribution to the sample distribution
we can calculate an adjustment Factor
this is just the ratio of the proportion
in the universe to the proportion in the
sample um so earlier I said that I had
like heavily oversampled older folks and
indeed when we use this to create an
adjustment factor and multiply that into
our weight you can see that the weights
for Young Folks are just about twice
what they are for old folks so that's
one variable how does riking do this for
the rest of the distribution well we
proceed variable by variable doing the
same exact process um once we go through
another stage of the algorithm we weight
by race um what we're going to do is
multiply that weight into the existing
age weight we have and we'll get a
weight distribution that looks like this
um for race um notice though that after
I did that correction to
make our sample means match on marginals
match our universe means on Race here we
imbalanced the age ones right because we
Rak one way on age then we red one the
other way
on Race that messes things up slightly
and so we have to iterate through again
and again and again and slowly these
will converge so that all of the
different means match of course we're
not going to do this by hand usually
we'd use a package like Autumn or the
survey package this is what it looks
like to set this up and run it pretty
quickly using the Autumn Library just
because it's pretty transparent in
setting up the target frame really
quickly um so again we know these
population prop proportions CU we set it
up we know
these if we rake those weights and then
we weight by it and calculate a weighted
mean we'll fully recover our treatment
effect from earlier so in some senses
this is like horrifically simplistic
right but I do want to suggest that
compared to what most of survey
inferences history was like this isn't
that bad of an approximation of what the
process was like right if we have a
pretty good sample with from a universe
where we have pretty high response rates
you can get very very close to
representative estimates just by raking
on a couple of demographic features um
what's changed well um welcome to raking
on hard mode um this is basically a
legally required slide if you give a
survey talk so let's get through it
everybody knows phone response rates are
now frequently less than
1% um many and apologies for the
apologies for the buzzing there's a
backend that people can go in so now
many survey reearch researchers use
online panels non-probability sample
methods for cost or other reasons our
outcomes are frequently related
to propensity to respond in really awful
ways so for example when I was doing
that multiarm RCT about the covid
vaccine you can probably have the
intuition that the sort of person who
doesn't answer a
survey is the sort of person who doesn't
want to get a covid vaccine or
equivalently you might have the
intuition that someone someone who's
more likely to vote for Trump from
certain populations is less likely to
want to answer a poll as well um and so
our respondents are getting increasingly
weird in ways we can't just wait out
along a small sense of census
demographics um I'd call this living in
a world of non-ignorable non-response
um so what does that effect have on what
what does this how does this affect our
waiting well so we're trying to wait to
cover all of the issues our sampling
can't so it puts a huge amount of
pressure on waiting um so on the left
here I actually have everything that the
New York Times waited that 2024
Battleground State poll on I think
they're 12 variables here I was
pleasantly surprised it fit on one slide
um and you'll notice too that a lot of
these things aren't super easy to pull
from the Census right you'll see a lot
of these are stated as models from L2 L2
is a voter file vendor right we don't
know those with nearly as much certainty
of course we also care not just about
like Univar representations of these we
care about interactions um apor polling
Consortium research body put out this
really beautiful careful paper after the
2016 election for example showing that
the intersection of education and race
was really critical in getting the right
estimates in a lot of Midwestern states
maybe you treat that as a three-way
interaction and you do race by education
by region um very quickly we're building
up a huge demand on what we expect our
weights to do and lastly I want to
suggest that many of these variables are
included not because we believe that
like State you know this region the
state region you're in or home ownership
is like the direct thing that determines
your
politics we think that those things are
mildly correlated with some difficult to
measure underlying factor that might
shape your politics right so a lot of
the things on the latter half of this
list are things I heard pollsters
talking about at apore
2022 as I don't know exactly why but
some of these things have very good
relationships if we try to like fix our
weights that didn't go quite right in
2020 right it's a hard problem um so
what effect does this have if we try to
solve this with raking if we try to look
at a list like
this and build weights well raking on
everything using raking for this isn't
free in many cases raking on everything
we want to doesn't even really converge
right so we end up picking and choosing
which variables interactions matter the
most to us um you know maybe through
Theory right like we know oh in 2016 it
was this race and education thing maybe
in 2020 we think it's voter history
helps because knowing who voted in the
primary matters a lot um we can't put
everything in and we can't and things
have to be either in and out of the
model right there's a second class of
issues here when we start trying to keep
increasing the amount of waiting we're
doing which I'd broadly call variance
problems um raking on more Dimensions
can lower bias but it often adds
variance not universally but that's
broadly the rule um this leads to survey
researchers using a lot of very
personally things that I would call very
hacky or very heris to try to control
the variance of their weights and of
their weighted estimates um they rules
like okay so a kish's design effect
tells you compared to a simple a design
where you could treat your data as a
simple random sample how much larger is
would the variance of your weighted
estimates be right so a factor of one a
kisha's design effect of 1.5 would be
under those assumptions it' be the
variance would be 1.5 Times Higher
there's heris rules in the survey
literature about saying like we don't
want a kish's design effect higher than
1.5 if you get that go back to the
beginning choose slightly fewer things
in your rank
ging try
again that doesn't seem as applicable in
a world where our samples are
increasingly bad right like if someone
made a rule in 20 2020 like
20 oh I don't know like 2001 about this
right there's a couple of papers
discussing rules for this if people
weren't using non-probability panels as
extensively when they came up with these
rules of thumb if they're not doing
something that looks like the task we're
doing is this rule applicable not always
um and then of course there're heris
things like trimming the weight saying
like too much Varian is being added to
our weighted estimates by the VAR Tales
of our
weights so let's sort of restate some of
the things I was complaining about as
sort of things that maybe an alternative
algorithm could solve um here we've got
here I've got three um one thing that's
a consistent problem is variables are
either in or out in the raking framework
um you can't say for example I think I
care a little bit about the intersection
of race and gender but maybe not that
much that's not an easy thing to do we
also have a fairly limited tool set of
tools to manage the variance of our
estimates
so for example um if I want to and often
those things are really entangled with
our bias too right because if we want to
remove variables to solve our variance
issues we're also messing with bias
potentially so that's not great and
lastly this is more of a theoretical
point but it's not really clear in what
sense the raking solution is optimal um
and by that I mean is there a loss
function we're optimizing how do I know
this set of weights is better than that
sets of weights on what line is that
true um it's a pretty theoretical point
but it will make more sense and help
clarify like what other Alternatives
could exist as I get later into the talk
so let's jump into regularized raking um
Barett at all
introduce um regularized raking and show
that the broader representative sample
weights problem right how do we assign
weights um to make a unre representative
sample to use rep to make estimates
about a general population can be stood
as understood as this optimization
problem um this is pretty genericized
right like there's not enough here to
know what's going on without going
through how they're defining each of
these broader terms so let's step
through it term by term um first we've
got F and F Target these are functions
of our sample and our Target population
uh this could be as simple as an
expected value right you could be saying
I want the
population proportion of age to be the
same in the population and the Target
and then we'll also have some loss
function L which clarifies how we want F
and F Target to be close this can be
very simple or you can make it much more
complex and the flexibility there is
part of the benefit of this
framework so let's go through some
examples of some la loss functions um
one of the simplest is the equality loss
either your your population either your
s weighted sample average is exactly
equal to your population Target or the
loss is infinite right in optimization
we use infinite loss to mean that's an
inadmissible solution or that doesn't
work
so this is probably the simplest way you
could do this and if we do this for all
of the variables we're raking on this is
actually exactly what vanilla raking
requires right we require that within
tolerance the things that we're raking
on exactly match their population
proportions after raking um but that
feels a little constraining right so
just to push the boat out a little let's
do something like ever so slightly more
exciting and get Vince a little bit more
excited what if we want things to be
approximately balanced right what if I
don't care that my sample is exactly 50%
to some
Epsilon young it's fine if it's 49 to
51 that would expand the realm of
possible solutions to this optimization
problem right if we can have solutions
to this problem that are a little bit
better or a little bit more flexible and
a little bit more tolerant maybe that
lets us find other solutions to building
weights that might be better in some
other sense this still feels inflexible
though right like why is some range of
values coming out of matching our
population our sample to our Target
infinitely bad that that doesn't really
jive with what we think about um now
Vince is getting very excited um because
this is boring if you're coming from a
machine learning background but maybe a
little bit more exciting if you've
mostly worked with survey weights you
can in fact build in uh continuous loss
here so you can say that I I think that
I would like you know closer is better
right so I want some sort of squared
loss on a term like race the
intersection of race and education
closer to the population totals on those
would be better but I'm not going to say
that it's a failed attempt at building
weights if it doesn't work um and I've
already sort of hinted at this but just
to sort of show how far this can go and
get Vince re really really excited a
little concerningly excited we can have
different loss functions for different
functions of our data right so we can
require the equality loss on all of our
single dimensions of our data so say our
on Race on education on gender on
everything on every single Dimension we
want exact equality to population totals
but have a least squares loss on all of
our interactions in a framework like
that even if you couldn't fit all of
those
interactions in a in a model where you
required equality on them you'd be fine
um and then lastly just to sort of push
it even a little further we don't have
to have these all be on the same scale
right we could say certain interactions
are worth more to us right so we want it
be to be more painful to be slightly
less accurate on the intersection of
race and education because that's
something we know from past years is
really important um cool let's talk
about the regularizing term don't worry
I'm not going to bring Vince back um we
of course don't just care about
adherence to population totals when
we're building weights right what about
variance the shape of the distribution
of the weights so we might want weights
that have some other property other than
their relationship to population total
so we want could want weights that are
as uniform as possible as close to some
other Target
distribution with different variance
properties um you know you can you can
think of this like a sort of like budget
Corner Store generic prior right um and
so RW can be chosen from a variety of
regularizers that encode these
preferences for you and we have a
hyperparameter Lambda that allows us to
make more explicit tradeoffs between how
close we are to population totals and
how close we
are or excuse me how close we are to how
how we trade off between our loss and
our regularization so probably the
simplest of these is just negative
entropy right we want our weights to be
as uniform as possible subject to all of
our other
constraints um this is the other half of
what vanilla raking does and it's a
little counterintuitive so I want to try
to give at least an attempt at the
intuition here the idea is that subject
to all of other other constraints being
met we want sort of the weights
distribution that gives us the least
additional information encoded right the
least
additional preference of how the weight
should be shaped things like that we
could also do a k Divergence which is a
measure of closeness and distribution to
some other distribution that we think is
desirable so if we want our weights to
look more like a normal distribution or
be smoother or what have you we have a
way to do that um and then lastly
there's some constraints um we want
positive weights non- negative weights
are useful not all estimators play well
with negative weights right um not all
people you share weights with play well
with negative weights sometimes they
think that's like an error or a problem
even if even though increasingly a large
number of tools can produce negative
weights we also want the weights to sum
to one or you could rescale them to sum
to n
um yeah so recapping just talking about
that point I made about what vanilla
raking does it requires equality loss on
all of the raking Dimensions right our
po our sample proportions after waiting
need to exactly match our Target
proportions and there's a negative
entropy regularizer um so hopefully this
gives some clarity for you about what
raking when you build weights with it
optimizes for right this
is for me at least coming from like a
machine learning
background equality loss feels like a
very strong WR heavy-handed thing to use
in a lot of these situations so framing
the problem like this makes it clear
that this is quite strong so as we've
seen there's a bunch of other CH choices
we could make are any of them better
that's the next
section um so getting into Data I'll be
using a poll conducted by Pew in 2016
with like 2,000 likely voter respondents
the outcome of Interest here will be
vote margin or the number of Voters who
favored Clinton minus those who favored
Trump um I really like this data set for
a couple of different reasons so it's
easy access um it's available cc0 so you
can use it in teaching whatever you want
um as part of kahi at all's wonderful
book um Target estimation and adjustment
waiting for survey a it has such a long
title I'll say it at the end of the talk
where I have it on a slide um so it's
available you can go pull it and play
with this example unlike if I tried to
use a survey that had a bunch of
commercial voter file data appended to
it that's more complicated to share in a
talk like this there's also a correct
answer to this right Hillary run the
national vote share by 2 point uh vote
margin by 2.2% so we know that and we
can if not like calibrate our estimates
exactly to it because it's in the past
and we could hack our way to get there
we can at least know whether things are
close there's also a pretty broad
variety of co-variates so if I want to
really heavily expand out what I'm
waiting on here I can do that for this
talk lastly I'll be using estimates from
the 2016
CES as for to build Target distributions
again this is an ideal ideally I'd be
waiting to like a voter file um but
since again that's commercial data this
works it's a huge 50 plus thousand
person survey it's very representative
of the American public and it has a lot
of useful political data in it so cool
um we'll walk through an example in R
raking weights and then using RSW the
python package um from the Barett at all
paper to build some
familiarity um first this is super
simple our raing our waiting formula
will just be four basic variables
age gender race and
region um this should go badly right I
said education was important here and
I'm not using it but just for by way of
an example I have a convenience function
that's turning this little r formula
into a weighted into targets design
matrices targets for RSW to use and if
we calculate the vote margin here this
will have Hillary winning by just about
nine points so obviously not true but
just for the sake of showing this versus
the basic basic syntax in RSW um so
we'll have a design Matrix here this is
basically just a Col for every
observation a column of zeros or ones
for each variable in the data set we'll
have a Target which is just a list of
population per uh population per uh
proportions for every one of those
variables um then we define losses a reg
and a regularizer in this case both of
these are pretty boring right I'm just
saying I want the equality loss for
purposes of illustration on every single
variable in our Target not a lot going
on here the regularizer stock standard
entropy regularizer you get out a vector
of Weights you get out adherence to the
the to the Target means from your
weighted sample right so you can go back
and check how close are all of my
resulting distributions to my target um
and you get out some features of the
solver which I won't talk about today um
um and so just sort of to like go back
to that like what is vanilla riking well
this matches exactly what I got earlier
to five decimal places I think um and if
I plot a distribution of the weights um
there's nearly perfect overlap and I
suspect if I played with the tolerances
the little bit of the tail around one
would pop right up and we'd be right on
top of each other so it's just a
different way to restate the weights now
let's move on to something that actually
RSW can do something different in um so
Formula 2 um this is getting into
something more realistic for this data
said um got age gender and then all of
the intersections of race region and
education um now we have a very accurate
estimate we're only like a percent off
when we rake um I think most posters
would be really happy with this in 20 in
2016 right um but of course we only
figured out after the fact that we
needed all of these things in like 2018
to get the weights right so that's a
challenge
um let's see if we could push and notice
by the way that in order to get this to
work I had to make education uh you know
I had four levels of Education to get
this to fit I needed to make education
three ways so just have less than high
school high school or college or greater
um we're really like coming up against
the limits of what raking can do for us
now let's take advantage of regularized
raking um this really pushes things I
think for people who have raked weights
before this is going to be a lot further
than you'd be comfortable going right um
I've got state in here which is a
massive variable with a lot of levels um
I've been able to include race region
and education without making it
three-way without making it reducing the
number of levels in it how did I do that
well I'm taking advantage of the fact
that I don't have to have exact equality
on everything basically what I'm doing
is I'm saying for the main effects that
is just
for all of the marginal distributions
I'm requiring exact equality here um and
then for all of the interaction terms so
everything later in the design
Matrix were requiring a least squares
loss um and so that can make allow us to
wait on a lot more things
without and well still having the
weights converge and still having the
weights be good how does this do um so
the point estimate is great it's you
know basically bang on I'm less excited
about that than almost everything else
here though um some really nice things
here that I also noticed the standard
error is wonderful right like it's lower
than the example the previous example by
just a little bit despite the fact we're
we've added relatively more variables
into our raking um right like we added
in a big variable like State and we
still have lower standard errors that's
lovely um also if you look at the
distribution of the weights here that R
distribution is starting to look a
little bit tortured right you've got a
bunch of weird bumps going on here
things are looking a little shaky like
it had to build some pretty a pretty
uneven shape to this distribution to get
things to fit it all because of all of
those interaction terms we had to match
exactly on but with the regularized
raking one because we've allowed a
little bit more flexibility on all the
interactions because we've got some
regularization in the myths this is
still a pretty smooth
distribution cool um so far I've mostly
been talking about examples where a lot
of the gain we're getting is from the
sort of flexibility of choosing terms in
the model and how they'll be fit I want
to push it just a little bit further to
show how much the regularization can
help right um and sort of focus on that
side for a little um so this is like a
really bad idea to rake on right this is
the six way six way interaction between
everything but State basically um you
don't want to do that um oh and I added
party ID too um so this wouldn't fit
with
raking um this is something like 2,000
columns in the design Matrix which is a
bad idea um and this is the sort of
situation in
which regularized estimator becomes
increasingly important um I wanted to
make this easy to reproduce so I didn't
do like a ton of search over different
values of Lambda but you can see that
the regularization is powerful enough to
move
around that point estimate quite a lot
um and in general what I found is what
you'd expect of course is the more
you've got going on with different terms
in your model more complex losses more
flexibility the more you can scale that
up to sort of keep the weights um from
getting too wild so I didn't want to
make this a talk where I like focus on
doing the Bake Off thing about how to
minmax all the different terms in this I
more wanted to introduce the idea but I
at least wanted to give a quick example
where this matters a little cool so so
far I've been talking about everything
in the sort
of comparing a very simple algorithm to
something very complex that's like a
classic I have a new method let me beat
down on a weaker method let's compare it
to some of the more interesting stuff in
the world right like what would the um
Guardians of the polling Galaxy if you
want um say about this right um so let's
compare to some other modern options
I'll start with multi-level regression
and poststratification
um so we're going to use a regression so
in these we use a regularized model to
predict the outcome trained on our
sample and then we post stratify those
estimates right what are some advantages
and disadvantages of regularized raking
versus that well with regularized raking
you get typical weights which can be
applied to any outcome this is really
practical right in a lot of workplaces
if you need weights because that what
what gets fed into the code for your
banner book or how things get up online
on your site or what have you this is a
lot simpler regularize raking for most
versions of MRP versus most versions of
MRP or like large basan models that you
could fit is going to be orders of
magnitude faster um I can fit
regularized raking to on the order of a
million observations in under a minute
um that again can matter especially if
you're in an environment where you're
turning around around a lot of survey
research really quickly and then often
this is probably the most challenging
point or the most speculative point but
often a little regularization just goes
a long way the Gap from going to no
regularization whatsoever no very
inflexible model to just a little bit
makes a huge difference in my experience
of course sometimes you want to be a
good basan you want the whole posterior
distribution you want a natural way to
include measurement error missing data
any of the things that working with Baye
just makes your life so much easier for
um for most like true small area
estimation type problems something like
MRP or more heavily regularized estimate
will be more efficient um another thing
you could compare this to is multi-level
calibration um this also takes an
optimization approach it requires exact
matching on the marginals more
flexibility on the interactions and for
each successive going from like two-way
to three-way to four-way interactions
each term gets more flexibility and how
close it has to match the population
totals um regularized raking compared to
this is going to allow you greater
flexibility in defining your loss how
much regularization you're putting in
you retain more ability to make
trade-offs um that said multi-level
calibration if I wanted like a oneandone
tool for for making actual survey rates
this is probably what I'd go to um and
you'll get the most value out of
approximate balance without having to
iterate on all these different
interactions in your model this way cool
so to wrap up I've been talking only
about waiting today so I really do want
to emphasize that good sampling matters
and probably more than how you wait in
most cases selection of waiting
variables is much more important than
like how you built put them into a model
to wait things that said weight is
entangled with those right because if
you have more flexibility and how you
can
include variables in a model uh you're
going to have a better time um
regularized raking I think is a great
solution in this space maybe even as
like a first step into regularized
survey survey estimators right because
you can make very small changes to the
existing formula you have start building
in in regularization slowly and sort of
build up a more complex model from there
so it's a very nice practical applied
tool cool thanks very
much oh yeah and that's Q that's the QR
code for the talk if you want all the
reproduction
materials we have time for a few
questions so show it it was excellent
talk um and the question I was going to
ask was for a regularizer could you like
could you have a regularizer uh involve
say like the design effect or like
things involving the weights directly
instead of check like still checking
afterwards if it meets those criteria
yeah I've seen people do a lot of
different interesting things with it um
basically you just need to be able to
Define some optimization related
functions of whatever you're doing and
if you can do that you can have pretty
much whatever you want um so it
depending on whether or not what you
want to like have this be a function of
you might need to write some new code
right the the package to find some basic
regularizers but if you want something
new you might need to do a little bit of
work on the back end but yeah you could
definitely do something like that and it
seems like you can you showed us an
example where you can include multiple
regularization terms like one for the
interactions and one for the base
variables it seems you can kind of just
add add as much as you want to to an
extent yeah you can build it up
iteratively right you can so for example
like the most basic thing you could do
is say okay we have reg you know like a
simple entropy
regularizer and we want to encode a
really strong preferences that that our
weights are between 10 and one10 right
so like a typical adding a floor and a
cap type of thing and you can basically
just stack those together really
quickly another question good time few
more I saw a question and I guess the
regularization helps you choose which
variables that are worth waiting right
again it tosses one that doesn't think
is worth even waiting so it's I guess
it'll because there's generalization
here right um it'll depend on what
regularizer you choose um so it could be
something on the the shape of the
distribution or it could be something
more interesting than that but but yeah
I mean Bas that's like one of your
options
right
right let's just
Che so I'll give everyone last one last
chance to ask talk I get to the
front as he goes through the maze to the
front all right well thank you very much
big round of applause everybody thank
[Applause]
you all right and that concludes 2023 as
far as the meup is concerned so
everyone see you next year whoever wants
to give a talk be in touch with me that
goes for virtual in person or I could
just start pointing at people and tell
them they're going to give a talk and
that is how this happens sometimes uh
some Andy did volunteer for us but other
times I said you're speaking so that's
we'll do what we have to do for those of
you that are here in person we're going
to go to arts and crafts bar those of
you that are at home have fun doing
whatever it is going to do for the rest
of your evening or day depending what
time zone you're in so everyone thank
you for all for being here thank you for
watching and we'll see everyone soon hi
everybody